[Music]
danielle starts off this hour in reading
pennsylvania hi danielle how are you
hi there i'm good god what's up
my question is
that i've been working on my
snowball and
i am co-signed on some of my son's
student loans
and
i know this was before i knew better
so do i count that in my
snowball
yes ma'am because
co-signing means if he doesn't pay you
do
yes that's what we call a contingent
liability in accounting class
and so um
now how much student loan debt does
said sun have
that i am assigned to or cosigned on
it's um
38 000 co-signed with him and then i do
have my own parent plus loan that's 19.
so okay and what other debt do you have
uh a car
and uh how much
i'm gonna i think it's about 22 000 left
on it
and then a
uh credit card that i've been i
consolidated and i'm paying it
and it's about 12 000 right now mm-hmm
okay
and um
what's your household income
68 000.
okay
all right
and you're single how old are you
52.
okay
all right
the car is pretty expensive it's not a
complete deal breaker but you got a lot
of other stuff you're pedaling through
and um
you know you got 60 000 before we get to
junior's loans
so how old is junior
25.
how's he doing financially
um pretty well uh
well i don't think i can say that he
does manage his money well
and he makes his payments every month um
right now i would say he probably
makes about
17 an hour and he just moved into his
first apartment
out of state actually so
you know he's doing his own grown-up
thing yeah okay
well the problem is if he doesn't do it
you get to because of the co-signing
yeah so that's why i was asking about
his uh health
financially um
well what i'm gonna do is put those at
the end of your deal
and while you're working through your
debt snowball you need to share your
story with him pretty regularly
so he starts to catch on that maybe he
ought to do this you don't need to call
him up every day and tell him he needs
to do it but you need to tell him all
about you
so you become an inspiration for him
okay and then after doing that for a
while you can say stuff drop in there
too like and i'm really worried about
these student loans they're bothering me
they're keeping me up at night those
that co-signing oh i wish i hadn't done
that i just feel so bad about it and let
him feel bad that his mama feels bad and
he gets his butt in gear and pays him
off
i'm not above i'm not above shaming him
into it okay because it's for his own
good by the way as soon as he gets his
tail and gear and starts making more
than 17 did he get the degree
he did and not even in in
professional writing
okay so he he was working for a digital
marketing company
for a while doing the writing thing and
a lot more than 17 an hour then
well at the time
this was right out of
what as soon as he finished school and
so i i think that
it's a small business and the guy wasn't
quite that generous oh okay
well a digital marketing writer would
make a lot more than 17 an hour though
so i mean in the real world if he got
out here and did something what's he
right now what's he do now
he's working for fedex okay cool
all right and he also has a online
business that he does um like flipping
sneakers and things he's always been a
hustler he he definitely is making money
and wanted to start an actual brick and
mortar business doing that but i already
you know discussed with him there's not
a chance with all this student loan that
you're going to be able to get you know
something so you really got to work on
this but
i talked to somebody the other day about
a sneaker thing and the kid was
making a bazillion dollars so he made
like 60 000 bucks selling sneakers on
ebay oh yeah he
when he did live at home boxes were
coming and going every day it was a
serious amount of
moving going on there all right okay i'm
are you in financial peace university
i'm not okay i want you to go through
financial peace university i'm gonna
give you a ramsay plus membership
because i want i want our team to wrap
our arms around you give you a big hug
and help you walk through this um and
i'm also going to give you one to give
to him as a gift
and you just call him up and you just
say hey listen i'm working this plan and
i'm so excited about it and i just want
you to know it's there and and you know
we could even do it together virtually
long distance or whatever and
you don't need to ever wag your finger
at him and shame him but i want him to
hear how inspiring you are and how fired
up you are and i want him to see the
same sets of information you're seeing
on how to do this so that you can
uh
you know you can we can get him moving
along i think he might be making more
money than we think he's than you think
he's making and he needs to put it all
on the stinking student loan so that you
don't have to deal with it ever like i
want to pay it off if he could pay it
off this year and make me happy
and then you don't have to worry about
it the faster he pays it off the quicker
it's off your books meanwhile we're
going to get you out of that so you hang
on i'm gonna have kelly pick up and
kelly ramsey plus for uh junior and for
mom yeah one for each and let's get them
in there and let's get them through
financial peace university and uh learn
how to do this stuff then they can get
on here and do a
mother-son debt-free scream that would
just be awesomeness be about as good as
it gets
so here's the thing
um if you if you think student loans are
a good idea here's what i want you to do
through the holidays a lot of you have
things you're looking for something to
watch during the holidays
jump on apple tv
or uh
amazon prime or on
google play and watch borrowed future
our documentary
your mind will come unglued from your
head you just blow your mind
this this documentary on the evils of
the student loan world
and how out of control just about every
segment of that world is
will
you know you'll never let a person you
know get student loan debt again after
you see this
borrowed future full-length documentary
by
ramsey networks we put it together here
and it's world-class it's uh very well
done several hundred thousand folks have
already viewed it we are stirring up a
holy ruckus with this thing
be sure you watch it through the
holidays borrowed future again apple tv
google play or prime video
uh you can catch it anywhere amazon
prime i mean and there you go don't miss
it that's what she's talking about this
is the ramsey show